R
CANDIDATEN FOR NEVADA, ADAM
LAXALT.
IN 1919, WORLD WAR I JUST
FINISHED.
HIS WIFE SHIELDED WILSON.
SHE RAN THE WHOLE ADMINISTRATION
WITHOUT TELLING ANYBODY.
THE 32nd PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, FDR.
HE SUFFERED FROM POLIO AND LOST
THE ABILITY TO WALK AT THE AGE
OF 39 ROUGHLY.
HE WENT ON TO WIN FOUR ELECTIONS
IN A ROW, ALL IN A WHEELCHAIR.
BUT MOST OF THE COUNTRY DIDN'T
KNOW HE WAS IN A WHEELCHAIR.
HE USED A CANE OR SOMEONE'S ARM
FOR BALANCE.
AND THE SECRET SERVICE HAD
PICTURES DESTROYED THAT WERE
TAKEN BY ROGUE JOURNALISTS.
JOHN KENNEDY WORE A WHACK BRACE
AND WAS TREATED WITH AND
QUESTION LIESERS AND OPIOID PAIN
SHOTS.
YOU WOULD THINK IT COULDN'T
HAPPEN TODAY WITH AM AS
EVERYWHERE.
YOU WOULD BE WRONG.
THE PANDEMIC FORCED JOE BIDEN
INTO THE BASEMENT WHERE HE COULD
HIDE SOME OF HIS.
AND THE MEDIA COVERED UP.
>> DR. BIDEN IS FOR IT?
, MR. PRESIDENT?
>> DR. BIDEN THINKS -- MY WIFE
THINKS THAT -- THAT I -- THAT WE
ARE DOING SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT.
THE MOST COMMON PRICE OF GAS IN
AMERICA IS $3.39, DOWN FROM OVER
$5 WHEN I TOOK OFFICE.
BRIAN: IT WAS $2.84 WHEN HE TOOK
OFFICE AND IT'S NOW $3.72.
HI, GOOD NIGHT EVERYBODY.
I DO SUPPORT FRACKING AND I
DON'T -- I DON'T -- I SUPPORT
FRACKING AND I STAND AND I DO
SUPPORT FRACKING.
I DON'T EVER RECALL IN THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY DO THEY SAY
TAKE OUR TIRED HUDDLED MASSES
AND PUT THEM ON A BUS.
HE GOT HIS PENNSYLVANIA HOUSE --
>> MR. FETTERMAN WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE ON.
BRIAN: JOHN FETTERMAN IS NOT
WELL.
IT'S CRYSTAL CLEAR TO ANYBODY
WHO WATCHED THAT DEBATE.
OR JUST WATCHED THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
HE WON'T TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE
PRESS.
AND HE WON'T RELEASE HIS MEDICAL
RECORDS SINCE THE STROKE.
HE'S NOT FIT FOR THE JOB OF
SENATOR.
BUT HIS ENABLERS ARE GOING ABOVE
AND BEYOND TO COVER UP FOR HIM.
>> JOHN FETTERMAN HAD SOME
SPEECH STRUGGLES DUE TO HIS
STROKE.
BUT HIS AUTHENTICITY WAS THERE.
>> HE HAD SOME REALLY STRONG
COMEBACKS.
>> FETTERMAN LOST THE BATTLE
LAST NIGHT BUT MAY HAVE WON THE
WAR.
BRIAN: THE PROTECTION ACROSS THE
NEEDS TO STOP.
WE CAN HAVE CONTROVERSIAL
CANDIDATE, EVEN RADICAL
CANDIDATES SOMETIMES.
BUT WE CAN'T HAVE INCAPABLE
CANDIDATES.
AND WE MUST UNDERSTAND THAT
FETTERMAN IN PENNSYLVANIA CANNOT
DO THE JOB AND IT BECO